one of the best long-term strategies for
selling stuff is always selling less
than your demand which means that if
there's a hundred people in line to buy
your thing only sell to 20 or 30 of them
not even 80 20 or 30 of them because it
shows the majority of people not a
minority the majority of people that you
are not available and what happens is
you get leverage in pricing you get to
pick the best clients you look at the
100 you go 80 20 and just pick the 20.
and so then you get better customers at
better prices that stay longer that have
positive word of mouth and then the
other 80 want you even more and then
they tell their friends and then the
next time you open your doors up you've
got a thousand people in line and you
pick 200 but the problem is most people
when they have a hundred will take all
100 and then not have demand they never
get past that so you have to let the
Goodwill stack so that the compounding
machine can begin so that you never go
hungry again